hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about history of Science
and Technology I am not in my natural
habitat so uh video on other things
might be a bit odd today but
um let's see well all kinds of
interesting questions
here um Elsie asks what are your
thoughts about how R&D has been done and
funded across history so we're talking
research and
development
well that's an interesting question I
think well let's go back to Antiquity
what kind of research and development
was done in Antiquity I think most of
what was interesting then was uh
military research and development and
from people like you know Alexander the
Great to people who were making use of
Archimedes as a consultant for the uh
Sicilian the Syracuse
military and so on a lot of kind of uh
uh the you know it was a a piece of a
function of the military Enterprise of
the
state I think other kinds of well I mean
certainly in in in many of these cases
there were large Municipal projects that
were done building aqueducts building
you know kinds of bridges and arches and
so on and I'm not sure whether that
would be something which would be
thought of as as sort of research and
development M whether that was just more
like the well let's construct this thing
and the construction of those things
required figuring stuff out um I
know I mean it's sort of a messy history
I suppose because
in uh this this kind of idea that one
would do sort of research and
development
disembodied from the the actual projects
and products that one was trying to get
out I think was a is sort of a thing of
modern times um I think back in those
days I mean I I kind of always wondered
the antia device this first example of a
mechanical computer that came from
sometime between 1 Century BC and 1
Century ad was found in a shipwreck
around 1900 uh on an island off the
coast of Greece that thing which is our
unique example of a kind of
computational mechanical device from
antiquity I've always thought you know
how was that made was there rantic CA
Factory somewhere you know would it be
the case that if we could do excavations
Under the city of Syracuse and Sicily or
underneath Athens or something like this
that we would somehow find kind of the
antia factory I don't think it was
probably a factory I think it was more
like a workshop where things were being
made sort of individually by people by
the way that whole process of doing sort
of archaeology under existing cities is
a is a challenging one and I've kind of
always assumed that one day there will
be kind of
autonomous uh sort of drilling devices
that will just be able you'll just sort
of put it in the ground and then it'll
go off for six months and it'll slowly
drill through and it'll find a bunch of
stuff and it will sort of reappear
having put in its uh in its cargo
container all kinds of interesting finds
from uh uh from what was sort of
discovered under the in places where you
couldn't sort of excavate from the top
now I suppose also when I think about
that the Excavating from the top thing
if you were prepared to do much more
work and if you were had many more kind
of autonomous digging devices and so on
and you'd sort of solve the problem of
Robotics then maybe even digging from
the top would be something that will be
feasible which it isn't right now
because you can't like take some
existing bustling City and dig a giant
hole in the middle of it to uh to find
archaeological objects I mean often
archaeological objects get found when
somebody for whatever reason digs a big
hole in the middle of a bustling City
for example they're going to build a new
skyscraper or something and I think this
happened in London for example uh and
you know they dig down and by golly they
find all kinds of interesting
archaeological kinds of things but in
any case the you know how was the antia
device made um you know it it uh and was
it doing research and development I I'm
assuming that most of if it was made it
was made by sort of an artisan or a
group of Artisans who then delivered it
to customers and it was a very simple
thing where there wasn't kind of this uh
this complicated chain now now when I
say deliver to customers I mean there
were certainly traders who would buy
things and kind of travel around and
then sell them to other people so the
supply chain wasn't necessarily person
who makes it sells it to
people but you know when it comes to
folks like Archimedes who certainly did
uh basic
research I think he did that as you know
he was kind of a a person's I don't know
what his means of support was I I don't
know whether that's even historically
known I mean some people like you know
Plato his family owned a bunch of
Vineyards and so he had kind of a a uh a
landowning business so to speak that was
independent of his efforts with the
academy and and so on I think uh well
another place where some sort of basic
researchy kinds of things were done I
think is the Library of Alexandria where
for example uclid worked and uh the not
quite sure what the funding source from
the Library of Alexandria was um whether
it was just a state function of kind of
the Roman Empire so to speak or whether
it was I'm sort of thinking that it was
and I mean somewhere there was a a
budget line item for Library of
Alexandria and you know the Library of
Alexandria was kind of like a university
and I think you know the other
possibility which I don't know the
answer to is whether people who went to
study there would pay for it I certainly
assume that Plato's Academy worked that
way that people who wanted to study
there would pay kind of a a fee just
like you know University fees today um
and you know that would have been the
way that sort of professors there got
funded I mean certainly in in many
systems kind of the the idea of the
University as middle person where you
know the university hires the professors
and students pay money to the university
that's not always worked that way I mean
even in for example Continental Europe
particularly Germany um in the 1800s
early 1900s and so on this notion of a
privat doent a person who had a license
to teach but the actual money they made
from teaching came from individual
students showing up to their lectures
and paying them for being able to come
to their lectures they had to have a a
state government license to teach but
kind of like many uh sort of uh
regulated professions today you know you
have a have to have a state license to
be a lawyer a doctor whatever else but
then it's up to you to collect the money
from your individual clients and so it
was with professors particularly in
Contin Europe um back you know 100 years
ago or so now
and I I wouldn't be surprised that that
system had existed I I think in some
form or another that system probably
existed through the Middle Ages and
probably back into Antiquity I mean it's
kind of an extreme version of rap my
professors so to speak that uh you know
your living comes from does this
individual student like the class you're
teaching little bit more like the
tutoring business I suppose but this was
for for larger scale classes but it was
done you know the professor collected
the money it wasn't like it went through
a kind of intermediate pipeline so to
speak I think in um you know if we look
to later times I think it's very common
for the court the king the state to have
a certain number of courtiers who were
sort of science oriented or R&D oriented
hanging around now whether those people
were kind of um uh whether whether they
were kind of I think many of them were
kind of general purpose as in well
you're going to do um you're going to uh
you know help with our fortifications
and you're going to help with our
history research and you're also going
to occasionally
entertain the uh the sort of the the
monarchy with Tales of science and so on
I mean we certainly know many examples
where that happened you know deart for
example famously was hir d by Queen
Cristiano of Sweden I think late in his
life unfortunately it turned out to be
late in his life to be kind of a a
person to hang out there and teach her a
bunch of stuff about philosophy
unfortunately caught a cold and died
soon after that that happened but that
was a case where it was kind of like
bring in a philosopher we want to have a
philosopher around and by the way the
queen is interested in learning
philosophy and I suppose a similar kind
of um uh let's see I mean we know that
for example uh you know I think I think
people like Kepler for example who
tended to sort of travel around he tried
to support himself from uh various kinds
of advising and uh you know he I know
his his book The Sixth corate snowflake
is dedicated to some particular King
Prince whatever who was kind of his uh
um his benefactor at the time I think
the um now now Kepler for example also
had sort of an entrepreneurial thing
going he was trying to figure out could
he make a business out of figuring out
given a wine CK how much wine was in the
CK without sort of opening it and
measuring it just by virtue of of sort
of figuring out how deep things were if
you poked one hole in it and saw how
that worked and then you looked at the
outer um solid Revolution so to speak of
the wine cast could you do sort of
pre-calculus to figure out the volume of
wine in it and that was kind of a
business he wanted to have I think I
think also there were there were other
people who were kind of using math for
businesses um at at various times of of
um um and by the way you know in terms
of of something like I'm I'm jumping
around a bit here but like in Babylonian
times where kind of the scribal schools
were the places where people were
getting taught sort of math kinds of
things they taught to do writing taught
to do kind of figuring out of mathy
kinds of things now was there some
person who was like I'm going to be the
the core R&D person who's going to
figure out what you can teach I don't
think so I think rather what happened
was that individual people would have
their methods for teaching this or that
and those would be relevant to Merchants
and Merchants would pay to get educated
or have have their children educated
about those kinds of things I know if
you go much later in time to like
feminar in 1200 ad in in um in Pisa in
Italy uh you know his business was
providing kind of books and Consulting
to Merchants who wanted to know how to
do calculations and he was like the
Hindu Arabic number system is a much
better way to do it you should use this
and there are these different methods
for calculating so this was kind of a a
combination I think sort of I'll do the
calculations and I'll show you how to do
the calculations kind of thing again
individual ual uh sort of an individual
achievement it's kind of more more like
uh somebody will figure out stuff to
write a book and then they'll make their
living from selling that
book there were other systems I mean I
think uh that the idea of sort of
research and development for its own
sake particularly basic research and
development for its own sake was not
something where it's more like
individual people would do it now there
were systems like in England for example
uh Isaac Newton was famous the Lucasian
professor of mathematics I think he was
in Cambridge I think he was like the
third one uh in the in the mid to late
1600s and that was kind of a a grant
from a person I think there there were
also regious professors who were granted
you know had uh uh the king had provided
the funding for that and um my
impression is that much like
universities today job number one was
supposed to be teaching and you know
research was something that you did
perhaps to support your teaching or for
your own entertainment so to speak I
mean Newton for instance kind of later
in his life took this gig being
controller of the mint uh you know the
kind of chairman of the Federal Reserve
type thing um because it was a step up
in the hierarchy of those times relative
to be a professor relative to being a
professor and it was also more money um
so you know I think think that the
research in support of teaching is
probably a thing that's been going on
for a long time the occasional sort of
research in for the the state is another
thing and people would get hired to do
things like gaus was hired to do a bunch
of things related to um uh land
surveying which is what kind of led him
to invent differential
geometry I think there were also quite
often things like State observatories I
mean the Babylonians had those and those
existed even much later I'm not quite
sure why people were funding kind of
state observatories back in Babylonian
times it was probably all tied up with
astrology and you know watch the Heavens
to predict what will happen on Earth but
certainly by the 1600s that was not what
was going on now it also has to be said
that there were plenty of people uh up
through the 1800s for sure who got to do
basic science because they were
independently wealthy in some way or
another and they were you know either it
was
um I think napia who invented logarithms
was a Scottish Baron of some kind um the
many people were uh uh were kind of uh
you know part of the the aristocracy in
England or or in other countries and you
know they rather than just sort of
hanging out and managing the land they
also sort of had a hobby of doing basic
science that led to many kinds of things
getting figured out and and sometimes
there were uh there were there were sort
of combinations like I think James Clerk
Maxwell was a little bit of a I've got
my fancy house in the very obscure part
of Scotland and I'm also you know hired
in in London or in Cambridge University
to be sort of a professor type um
and uh but I think the concept of kind
of well there were different forms of of
um you know usually governments would
fund things for very pragmatic reasons
like you know the
admiralty in in England would be funding
various kinds of
navigational uh research effectively
timekeeping research
eventually weather uh weather data
keeping but there were for very
pragmatic reasons like we want to
predict the weather we want to give
people reports on that we want to let
ships be able to navigate well those
types of things the idea that sort of
research should be done for its own sake
is something that occasionally would
happen as a result of just somebody
saying well it's interesting to think
philosophically about this which is kind
of like basic
research the the modern machinery of
kind of government funded basic research
sort of anonymous government funded
basic research I would say which was not
like we're hiring gotf free gnets to be
our court you know researcher type thing
or we're hiring Archimedes to be our
kind of Court scientist or whatever I
think the the an the mechanism of kind
of giant Anonymous things where the
government says we're putting out
billions of dollars and it's going to go
to the most deserving in some sense folk
sort of anonymously I think that's a
phenomenon of the second half of the
20th century um I I think that uh before
that time it was much more you know
there's a professor at a university and
people are paying for that professor and
so on rather than uh something where
just there's a blob of money allocated
and it's kind of flow to basic research
that whole mechanism got I think largely
invented well the Manhattan Project was
a big piece and then subsequently the
real acceleration of that was Sputnik in
1957 of the us being like Oh my gosh uh
kind of the Soviet Union has pulled
ahead and we've got to scramble and
support science and part of that
calculation was the um uh sort of
getting a human resource uh within the
country where there would be people who
would know about science and be
enthusiastic about science and that's
something by the way you know in the
Soviet Union one has the impression that
that was with a very sort of State
orchestrated mechanism that was a thing
that was kind of made to happen you know
there were universities created that
were teaching people about things that
were thought to be useful in science and
I think even from the founding of the
Soviet Union you know strangely enough
uh you know Lenin had written some
calculus book type things you know there
were there were people who were uh um
sort of there was a kind of an
intellectual interest there things got
very funky because well on the one hand
for example even in logic there were
sort of a there was the Soviet style of
logic which I think had a different
treatment of the L excluded middle that
not not p is the same as p and so on and
there were things that maybe came from
some interpretation of Hegel or who
knows what that fed into the sort of the
the the Communist sort of story and the
the uh the whole Marxist leninist
dialectical I don't know anything type
type mechanism but it was sort of
strange that even something like logic
became political I mean it's kind of a a
sad and cautionary tale for modern times
that even things that you think of as
being kind of look it's just sort of uh
uh just sort of pure thought if you go
far enough even those become political I
mean the fact that logic could become
political is is remarkable I think one
of the things that actually did drive a
lot of mathematical work in things like
the Soviet Union is that fundamentally
wasn't terribly political and if you
were going to be some kind of uh
academic intellectual type thing and you
didn't want to run a foul of you know
the Communist party so to speak then
working on math was a pretty good bet
because that really wasn't you know the
the question of what the value of this
particular integral was wasn't going to
be something where the party was going
to have this opinion versus that opinion
so I think that that did help Propel
things in in that case but again that
was a very sort of centrally managed
um research Enterprise and and there
were many sort of charming kind of
Soviet style efforts there there's one I
was just reminded of recently this thing
called trz which was this kind of Soviet
style uh plan for inventing new things
it's kind of a methodology where you say
you've got these different fields and
you say well I I've got one field where
people are studying elasticity of this
and another field where people are
studying flow of that and there's got to
be something in the middle that is kind
of the uh the thing that hasn't been
studied and if it was it would be an
invention kind of reminds me of some of
the AI doing science type ideas that
people have today that there're sort of
a a machine for inventing things and it
didn't work out terribly well in Soviet
Union I don't know of of any spectacular
sort of success stories from that but it
was kind of a a a part of the Machinery
of kind of the state planned kind of
research effort now I should say that
you know in the US this idea of for
example government Labs that got started
kind of I think largely in in World War
II and with things like the Manhattan
Project and then this idea of
universities being a place where the
government could give them money and
then they could do basic research I
think that's a phenomenon of the 1950s
and the Sputnik type period and really
in the the 1960s that developed big time
and I know when I was growing up in
England in the 1960s The Brain Drain of
people who uh like myself although I was
a little bit later than that you know
moved from England to the US because the
US was a sort of better climate for
doing science so to speak largely
because of ultimately because of
government funding um and uh that was
kind of a thing that that the US was a
sort of big winner in of getting sort of
the brains from lots of different
countries around the world I think that
still continues but
um uh you know there are other kinds of
um initiatives you know there plac times
when countries would say we're going to
solve this I mean in the US the Apollo
Program Space Program in general was a
very successful example of we're going
to solve this and we're going to align
kind of the government I mean that was
still it was a what was it I don't know
some fraction of a percent like half a
percent or something of the GDP of the
country was spent on things like the
Apollo program uh you know let's let's
it's a sort of a mission driven idea of
you know let's create this kind of um uh
let's let's do this thing this sort of
climbing Mount Everest type thing where
we don't know what its pragmatic kind of
consequences in the immediate time are
but it's something that is uh you know a
kind of a a thing that brings the
country together to do that you know I
have to say over the decades uh all
sorts of people told me you know
somebody should organize a Manhattan
Project of AI to kind of get to the
point where we finally have kind of AI
and it was always like well that's a
nice idea we don't really know what
direction to go so we can't really do
that although it is interesting in the
development of chat TPT for example that
that was a pour a lot of money into it
was an important part of making the
thing happen um although that was
commercial money in that case rather
than um uh rather than government money
and I think uh you know the the um but
there were other initiatives that were
very government L for example one the
the Japanese fifth generation project I
think that was initiated in
1981 where kind of the idea was and it's
kind of charming to look at this stuff
today because Japan had been a country
that had come up from kind of sort of
poor economic conditions after World War
II and so on and it really developed
particularly on the manufacturing side
and and kind of the vibe was a little
bit like China and Taiwan and so on
today that the vibe was oh they're just
copying stuff that's done in the west so
to speak and so the government in Japan
and you know a lot of that is what
happened although there was a lot of
innovation in manufacturing methods and
quality control and so on and uh the the
US for example in like the car industry
and things like that was very complacent
and uh really it kind of just was was
just sort of uh uh raced around so to
speak by something where you know you
could say well the core idea of cars
didn't come from Japan but certainly the
the kind of the the management
methodology to do with manufacturing at
high quality and and lower cost and so
on was that kind of story but anyway in
in the beginning of the 1980s the
Japanese government I suppose fed up
with being told that they were copying
everything said we're going to jump
ahead we're going to do the fifth
generation computer project I I never
completely knew what all the previous
generations were but it was very famous
because it was like oh my gosh you know
Japan is going to do AI because AI was a
thing back then it was mostly things
like expert systems and so on um and
Japan is going to do Ai and they're
going to jump ahead of the rest of the
world and it was a sort of a big
government project in Japan like many of
these things it really didn't work out
it didn't help that it was sort of the
wrong time in sort of the history of the
development of AI was a time when people
were very much into using things like
the prologue language kind of a logic
programming language where you state
goals and then you try and have the the
language fill in how to get to those
goals kind of like theor improving type
stuff and it was very that wasn't a good
language design for all kinds of reasons
which I could explain but that's sort of
a different issue but that was an effort
to kind of get uh sort of the government
in that case of Japan to go and sort of
jump in and um and and and make
something happen didn't work out very
well um I think that's always you know
this whole I one of the things that's
happened in in the US in modern times is
that it used to be the case in the 60s
and so on that sort of and the 50s and
and before that you know big R&D
projects it was a government project
nowadays it's much more at least
nominally commercially driven although
often when you really follow the money
there's a bunch of government money in
there that's driving what what's
happening so it um anyway that's a
that's a um it's a little bit of a story
there I mean I think the challenge of
understanding why should one fund basic
R&D is is a is a big one and you know
what tends to be the case I I've always
claimed that sort of monopolies are what
help basic R&D if you've got a monopoly
then any any progress that's made in
that field is most likely to benefit you
rather than anybody else and in so far
as the US is the biggest economy that's
something which sort of applies to the
us as well but I think the the question
of of why should a non monopolistic
player support basic R&D uh well you
know there are usually several reasons I
mean so it's often a human resource
development issue something where you
know you've got a country where for
example let's say you've got a country
where you're worried about cyber attacks
this is the I think Estonia as an
example of this where uh it's kind of
like my gosh we've got to get a lot of
people educated in stemlike subjects
because that's going to be important to
have kind of the the workforce we need
uh when we need that kind of technical
uh kind of ability to to fend off cyber
attacks I mean of course in in earlier
times and the origination of of public
education back in the late 1800s um the
uh you know in places like Prussia and
so on that was kind of the big story was
we need people who can be educated so
they can join the Army and uh you know
fight for the country type thing and I
think that you know that type of human
resource development has been seen as a
as a sort of important priority for
countries even if they're not the
country that will economically benefit
the most from from basic R&D um I think
it's uh uh you know there just many many
examples where things didn't work out
very well where people said we're going
to become you know we're going to buy
our way into being leaders in field XYZ
it occasionally works it usually does
not and and this you see the same thing
with people saying look at the startup
entrepreneurial ecosystem of the US and
Silicon Valley and New York and all
these other places you know we want to
transplant that to place XYZ how are we
going to do that well it's a government
story and it's funding and it's money
and it's this and it's that and it's and
then we import some people and usually
it doesn't work uh usually the kind of
the the Stars don't align to to make
those things come to pass although
sometimes they do and uh you know if you
look in the US for example sort of
interesting that Silicon Valley uh were
had many near-death experiences where
kind of all the major companies there
had imploded and then another you know
other ones have always ended up growing
From the Ashes and now there's probably
enough diversity there to support it but
at different times it wasn't clear for
example that the software industry would
be substantially based in Silicon Valley
there was a time when Utah was a big
place with word perfect and so on
Seattle obviously became a significant
place with Microsoft and and many other
companies um but uh you know in Austin
Texas is sort of coming up in the world
today but these things are it's it's a
little bit hard to know you know it
seemed like Scandinavia was doing well
for a while in in producing software
technology it seemed like Germany Berlin
particularly sort of for a while was
doing okay and then hasn't really been
much heard from since uh the UK for
example uh I would say had a a very
lackluster performance in that regard
for reasons that are a bit hard to
understand um and uh I mean ironically a
lot of the people who are sort of
leaders in those Industries in the US
came from those other countries so it's
it's not you know it's not something in
the water when they were growing up type
thing that um uh you know it's it's
something different about the kind of
whole
ecosystem anyway the
um
uh let's
see well let's see here's a one might be
a smaller one from Nitro saying I've
come AC Petr Nets and never had the
chance to dive deeply into them can I
give some historical concept about
context about that concept and their
applications and so on so Petry Nets
were developed by a guy called Carl Adam
Petri I think actually originally when
he was in high school I believe he was
interested in kind of finding an
idealized modelist I think is the
1940s an idealized model for chemical
reactions where it would be kind of kind
of like well you've got a certain amount
of chemical that can flow in here and in
order to have this reaction happen
you've got to have some number of units
of this chemical and some number of
units of that chemical and when you have
that those many units you can kind of
make another chemical and that can flow
through to another thing and so on so it
was kind of a a chemical engineering
chemistry story where things were made
discrete where you'd have discret lumps
of amounts of chemical and so on it's
sort of an interesting idea that then
got many legs I mean Petri himself uh
had a kind of a fairly long life um died
in
the least 1990s maybe even later than
that um I exchanged letters with him for
example um actually he was a quite
enthusiastic user of Mathematica and W
from language um and was very interested
in in making sort of connections between
petrinet and and that which we never
really managed to make at that time but
petrinet uh
became kind of they were sort of used
for this idealization of chemistry
subsequently various kinds of
idealizations of parallel processes of
various types and people have used them
as sort of ways to idealized systems I
would say that some piece of what came
out of that was things like uml um the
there are these okay so let's go back a
little bit earlier in history so
flowcharts the idea of representing
there's this then there's this and there
this that was sort of a thing that was
born of the idea of production lines for
manufacturing production lines
manufacturing that's around you know
turn of the 20th century
then the analysis of those things by
things like flowcharts the kind of the
disembodied analysis of a production
line as opposed to you know Henry Ford
going and just saying let's lay it out
this way the kind of more theoretical
level analysis was I think largely due
to to um Frank and lilan Gilbreth um who
were working in the
1920s and were kind of time and motion
experts so there was this whole
tradition of time and motion study which
I suppose is is sort of fed into in some
very cous way modern user experience
design because this was people going to
factories and saying look you know this
person if they have to walk further to
get from this to this to pick this thing
and put it on this if you rearrange the
Factory you can avoid that and time em
motion was people standing around with
stopwatches and clipboards kind of
watching what happened in factories and
so on and applied to other things as
well the Gil breaths charmingly I think
had 12 maybe even 13 children and one of
them one of the children wrote this uh
maybe maybe it was the mother maybe it
was little Gil I'm not sure but maybe it
was one of the children wrote this book
called Cheaper by the Dozen which was
the story of applying kind of time and
motion ideas to a a family with 12
children type thing I think it
subsequently became at least one maybe
two movies um about sort of Cheaper by
the Dozen but those were the efficiency
experts the time emotion efficiency
experts and by the way I think I think
it was L and Gilbreth invented
flowcharts um as this way to represent
those kinds of things and and that was
kind of a a tradition no doubt that
tradition was relevant to to Petri when
he was inventing Petri Nets um but that
tradition also sort of flowed through to
block diagrams and these kinds of things
and then to sort of modern methodologies
for representing kind of the flow of
stuff in some
process and and that's led to on the one
hand things like systems engineering
tools like our W system modeler based on
this language called modelica that is is
sort of a block diagram a way of
representing the relationship between
things like you've got this COG that is
kind of connected to this other Cog
we've got this wire that connects this
resistor to this transistor or something
these are things where you're you're
describing the structure of a system in
that case you're then creating a bunch
of ordinary differential equations and
solving them to represent the system in
the case of these other kinds of
flowcharts and things like that you're
more just saying this is what this is
sort of causal connections and that
that's sort of another tradition in
modern times is graphical models and
causal modeling of sort this event
causes this event I mean I would say in
our physics project we've taken kind of
that kind of causal modeling to the
extreme I was talking to Judea Pearl who
was kind of the originator of the sort
of causal models type movement in the
last I know 30 years or so and I was
asking him you know what's the biggest
causal uh Network you've you've seen and
I think he said a few tens of of uh
types of events you know each event in
those cases is a name thing like the uh
uh you know this particular thing goes
to this point on the production line or
this this thing happens I I was saying
well you know in our model of physics
we've got maybe 10 to the 400 Anonymous
events that make up the the the history
of SpaceTime so to speak so we we've
kind of taken the idea of of these kind
of causal Nets and almost flowcharts to
the absolute extreme of that's what
everything is made of in some sense um
but there are very very huge numbers of
events that are involved but anyway so
petrinet or by the way uh our causal
graphs um there is a limit of those
causal graphs which is Petr Nets
essentially what's happening is when
when you are saying in a Petr net
remember sort of originally came up in
doing sort of idealized chemistry in
idealized chemistry you are saying well
how much CO2 do I have how much uh water
do I have how much you know whatever and
you're just asking I don't care which
CO2 molecule it is I just care how many
CO2 molecules I have it's kind of like
it's it's then sort of this random soup
of CO2 molecules that are reacting with
other things whereas in our kind of
causal graphs every atom of space has a
story individual atoms of space not in
aggregate how many atoms of space are
there it's every individual one has a
causal story so to speak and so the way
you get to petrin Nets from causal
graphs is essentially equivalencing all
of the let's say atoms of space of a
particular type you just say I don't
care which one it is I just care how
many there are Al together and that
equivalencing gives you Petr Nets from
causal graphs and and so the the okay so
that that was that's one piece of the
whole story another place where they
show up is in the efforts particularly
in the 1970s 1980s to understand
parallel computation to understand sort
of formal models of parallel comput
computation what get called process
calcul um there are a variety of these
things that was communicating sequential
processes was one and these things are
relevant for things like designing
operating systems where you have
multiple processes running you can have
multiple threads you can have multiple
CPUs they're also relevant for Designing
kind of heterogeneous parallel Computing
systems there other things like Pi
calculus and so on I've never been a big
fan of these kinds of formalisms they
always seemed rather arbitrary and
complicated to me actually just recently
I wrote a piece about expression
evaluation and fundamental physics that
was kind of trying to understand from
the point of view of our physics project
and our kind of constructs of causal
graphs and so on how should one think
about things like expression evaluation
where you can have different parts of an
expression that can be evaluated in
parallel or that are required to be
evaluated sequentially and so on that
was sort of an interesting to me that
was a a great simplification and
clarification of sort of the history of
some of these process calcul now by the
way one thing to say is that some of
those process calcul and the work on
process calcul evolved into sort of an
algebraic approach to Quantum Computing
um I think largely through sort of the
introduction of category Theory into
kind of this process calculus type area
um in uh um the uh
um in in in trying to sort of formalize
these things and trying to find a
mathematical framework category Theory
seem to be relevant one I have to tell a
story this was probably how long ago six
seven eight years ago I was at the South
by Southwest uh sort of conference trade
show type thing where they had this this
trade show with a lot of wild exhibits
of you know people
advertising uh kind of put your ad in
the upper atmosphere with rockets that
would you know send out sort of uh
different colored um things that would
reenter the Earth's atmosphere and robot
arm Ms and and all kinds of wild uh sort
of personal medical uh things just a a
real collection of funky kinds of
invention type Technologies and I'm
wandering around this thing uh actually
with one of my kids um and we we stop at
this one booth and it's like what do you
do because you know the booth next door
had a robot arm and the other booth was
a was a re-entering Earth's atmosphere
with with ad material type thing and the
person there says we do categorification
of Petr Nets and I was like is that way
you tell everybody who walks up to this
booth because for most people that's
just utterly utterly mystifyingly
incomprehensible um I didn't really
quite get an answer to that but it was
kind of fun that that was a uh you know
along with the robot arms there was
categorification of Petr Nets and what
that was about was an attempt in that
particular case to use kind of the
petrinet idea mixed with category Theory
to be able to do things like represent
the kind of flow control of things like
blockchains and cryptocurrencies um in
order that you could essentially prove
theorems about what could happen and you
know can you double spend this token
things like this
so uh that's a bit of a story on on the
um on petrinet and so on and I I would
say that they petrinet sort of reappear
every few years as being a thing that's
kind of an
idealization of kind of the operation of
systems where there are many
interdependent Parts same thing that you
get causal graphs for um I I think
petronet in the bulk are probably less
interesting maybe I don't know the the
there things that have appeared as I say
in our in our physics project um the
they're they're part of kind of the the
set of tools that get used in thinking
about causal connections between things
and there's a there's a bunch of work uh
we've been doing about sort of
generalizing the way to think about
causality whether it's things cause
things or things prevent things from
happening that's a concept that does
exist in Petr Nets as well uh Petron
Nets also have a a well interesting
questions about what's decidable and
what's not petrin Nets generally are
quite decidable that is you can say will
this petrinet ever be able to get into
this state is there any way that this
kind of system of you know checkout for
a you know a self self-checkout you know
store or something can ever get tangled
up let's make a petronet representation
let's prove we can never get into the
state where you know the the the thing
is just offering people free cookies at
every every second or something um and
typically you can make those proofs in
petrinet they are decidable which tells
one that they're not really a general
representation of computation but they
do tend to be very computationally
complicated and they tend to be sort of
double exponential algorithms for
deciding some of these things although
they are
decidable
uh let's see a question here from Erin
do I have any Reflections on the recent
leadership situation at open Ai and the
history of decision-making for large
scientific research programs well I know
almost all the characters involved in
the in the recent open AI uh situation
um and uh uh it's one of those stories
where uh I
think sort
of it's it's kind of like technical debt
you build a bunch of software and some
things didn't get that you sort of put
in there at the beginning you didn't go
back and fix them again this was sort of
organizational debt of a structure that
really didn't make a lot of sense
anymore but and and really you know was
built for a quite different Vision I
mean I remember remember visiting open a
when it was a young company very much
just a research group type atmosphere
very different from what you get with
you know1 billion dollars of investment
money in it and and and things like this
and it's kind of like well you kind of
have to rethink these things now it's
sort of interesting to ask questions
about what kinds of corporate
organization make sense what do not um I
think that well you know people say that
the invention of the joint stock company
was one of the kind of great inventions
of the West so to speak that um uh the
joint stock company which was invented
what in 1600s and so on um and uh this
idea that you know you could own people
could own stock in a company and it
wasn't just the owners weren't
necessarily The Operators um that that
really enabled a huge amount of
industrial development and so on and I
think that um uh and that that's an
invention that didn't happen for example
in Asian countries for the most part and
so what you saw there was yes there was
a crafts person an artisan you know a
guild member but it was like kind of the
person who was doing the work was the
person who was making a living from it
not this notion of investors and so on I
have to say in my own life I've probably
not been leading the um quite the story
of the uh that was enabled by the kind
of joint stock company because I've you
know had the company without investors a
very much more of a uh you make it you
sell it type type situation um but uh
you know that idea of the joint stock
company and the idea that you could
incorporate you could make a thing who
would legally act like a a a person but
it was a an abstract thing it was a
company that had its own limited
liability you know they if it's like you
know the person can go bankrupt but that
doesn't mean that all their friends are
bankrupt as well and and so for the
company it was kind of like the idea is
you can incorporate it so that it is
treated in the law much like a person so
to speak and uh who can independently go
bankrupt or not and it doesn't kind of
and it doesn't flow
through immediately to the you know to
the owners of the company they're a sort
of separate layer so that that kind of
idea is you know a longtime idea and you
know in every country you know in the US
it's you know comma Inc in England it
would be comma LTD limited company um in
you know Germany what is it
gmbh
in can I do mention Spa is I think Italy
there and I don't know what most of
these things stand for but in every
country it was kind of a designator to
say this thing you're doing business
with is not really a person it's this
Incorporated thing and it's designated
that way well that was kind of a you
know that was a major Innovation then
another thing was public companies where
instead of it being kind of named
specific I just invested in your company
there's a public market where you can
buy and sell shares in companies and
that was a thing that became I would say
well by the late 1800s that was
certainly big but there had been there
had been previous examples going back to
the 1600s you know famously the south
sea bub Bubble was something a little
bit like that I was really Charmed you
know there was a the whole mechanism in
the south sea bubble where what happened
the um yes the what happened I think the
the the UK government the crown the king
at that time had a lot of debt I think
they've been involved in some Wars
something like that been involved in a
lot of debt meanwhile there was the
south sea company and the south sea
company was going to uh sort of uh um
was going to explore and uh
exploit the the uh kind of the value
from the South Seas
including many unsavory kinds of things
uh that that were going to be done but
in any case the south sea company was
like a um uh you know this is going to
be amazing this is going to be you know
this is a new thing in history it's
never you know it's it's um uh this is
this is finally new and people started
investing in it and the shares of the
south sea company climbed in value
dramatically really dramatically and
then in a in a thing that just has a
a resonance with things that have been
done quite recently the uh the king had
this great idea let me swap uh kind of
interest in the south sea company for
tea bills for for for you know for
essentially treasury bonds for bonds for
for debt from the country and so it's
like for for you investors out there um
you know it's it's like um
uh uh you know I've got a deal for you
instead of you holding on to to this
government debt that maybe it won't even
be repaid it's all kind of crummy get on
the rocket ship you know go uh exchange
your government debt for South Sea
shares which are going to the moon and
so a lot of people did including Isaac
Newton actually um and uh needless to
say it wouldn't be called the south sea
bubble unless it had popped like a
bubble which it did because there wasn't
real value there and well and I think it
was probably also mismanaged had all
kinds of other crazy craziness to it um
and actually there people who made a lot
of money in that whole runup to the
south sea bubble person um what was his
first name I don't remember last name
was Guy um and that's the person who
endowed guy's Hospital in London for
example um was was somebody who managed
to to ascend the south sea bubble and
and get out before the pop so to speak
but I was I was really Charmed I have to
say I was what was it I think it was the
um
uh you know people issuing
cryptocurrency and exchanging it for
sovereign debt was a thing that in the
Heyday of cryptocurrency of a few years
ago that was a thing that people were
seriously talking about and I was like
that's really amusing because it's you
know it's the south sea bubble all over
again um and you know people don't learn
from history well you know that's
perhaps why you know maybe that's that
that could be seen as sort of the Public
Service of of live streams like this is
let's talk about history because maybe
one can learn something from it and
don't repeat the south sea bubble so to
speak but in terms of the organization
of companies uh the I mean there were
other kinds of pseudo governmental
companies a little bit more like the way
I think many companies operate in China
right now which is kind of interwoven
governmental uh uh sort of private ENT
entities um and I think uh the um like
the East India Company for example was a
British one of those and and um maybe
there was some
Dutch I'm not sure if I remember that
history well but you know these these
companies would get very big and they
would start having armies and stuff like
this um and uh that
um uh that was that was a thing now you
know we got to sort of the stage of
public companies uh more and more kind
of ornate mechanisms for kind of the
flow of money you know Venture Capital
that was really a thing I guess Venture
Capital got started in
1950s um it which was again a kind of a
a professionalizing of what had been
just hey would you like to invest in my
company was kind of more like there are
people who are going to put money they
people who are saying I've got money I
need to invest in something what can I
invest it in let me invest in a venture
capital fund which will have people who
manage it who go actually make
investments in you know startup
companies or whatever that became a
thing I would say it became big by the
1980s um and uh that was sort of another
piece of the mechanism of companies now
you know there have been in in the US
for example there are different kinds of
companies like the traditionally es
Corps and C
Corps es Corps kind of small businesses
where kind of the tax that gets paid
gets paid by the individuals whereas C
Corps are sort of bigger ones which can
have ownership from things other than
individuals where you know the tax gets
paid by the company type thing um the uh
you shouldn't get me started about tax
and R&D and the and the disaster of the
US R&D tax credit and the absolute I
would say
irresponsible uh kind of inability of of
the US government even though I think
everybody kind of agrees about how this
should work this this kind of whole R&D
tax mechanism the the tax credit
mechanism expired and so that caused
endless trouble for people like me uh
dealing with companies that that spend a
lot of money on R&D and how that gets
handled for tax purposes but let me not
get started on that um but in any case
the um uh the thing that sort of
developed by the 1990s was sort of
increasing elaboration of kind of the
concept of a company like in the US the
concept of LLC limited liability
Corporation um as kind of a more
flexible vehicle for setting up a a
company with shareholders and and so on
or actually members um as they're called
in that particular case and and these
these sort of different different
mechanisms doing these things then
there' have been kind of you know
nonprofits have been a thing in the US
for a long time don't know quite their
history the the the sort of key
designation is 501c3 that's part of the
I mean there are 501c lots of other
things but 501c3 is kind of the the
scientific educational kind of R&D
oriented uh designation of a thing which
in the US the tax law says you know you
can you can if you give money to one of
those things you can deduct it from your
taxes uh even though you know it's a
philanthropic thing that's not true in
other countries um it's a you know it's
a US feature which has been very helpful
to the buildup of lots of kinds of
philanthropic efforts in the US but in
any case the um uh
so know that that's that's a thing and
the government governance of non profits
is a quite separate World from from
for-profit companies and it's had it's
had its share of uh I me it has a lot
more transparency in the US than than
for-profit companies in other countries
there's more transparency of for-profit
companies as well but um uh and there's
and sometimes there's even more
transparency of Charities and and
nonprofits in other countries but and
even more regulation about what they can
do and so on but um uh uh in in the case
of so so then there have been things
which are kind of combo versions of
these kinds of things like for example B
Corps are a thing of maybe a decade ago
so one of the issues with a corporation
is if you have stockholders in the
corporation then you as a as a manager
of the company have a or as a as a board
part of the board of the company have a
fiduciary responsibility to the people
who own the company so to speak the
shareholders of the company to make the
company do good things um now you know
that can be a very long term you can
have a calculation that well in the
short term it will be bad in the long
term it'll be good so long as you use
reasonable business judgment nobody can
really complain um sometimes they'll try
but but um uh really in the end the the
law kind of says that if you're using
reasonable judgment that's you can do
what you want to do to operate the
business but the one of the issues there
is that that responsibility is really
just to the owners of the business it's
not to for example customers It's Not To
The World At Large there's no there's no
it's not to the environment it's not to
any of these kinds of things it's just
like are the decisions I'm making
ultimately going to benefit the
shareholders of the company and that's
you know it could be the case that it
matters a lot to keep the customers
happy um because that is something that
um you know is obviously important for
the commercial success of the company it
it isn't sort of for the good of the
world it might actually be a cross
purposes with uh uh the the the greater
benefit of the company itself so this
idea came up of B corpse um and where
the kind of the charter of the company
says that in addition to it Being for
the Benefit of the shareholders it also
has other kind of other responsibilities
to the world so to speak typically to be
be a public benefit Corporation so to
speak open AI did not set itself up as
one of those I believe although it did
have sort of a mission statement and it
had this very complicated structure of a
nonprofit that had a capped profit uh
entity underneath it um the uh I I found
it somewhat amusing a quote from one of
the board members uh of open AI um who
said U uh in response to look you know
the things you're doing going to destroy
the company said uh apparently um well
that would not be inconsistent with the
mission statement of the company for it
not to exist will be compatible with the
mission statement of the company
probably I haven't read the mission
statement but it probably has to do with
you know we're going to make AI for the
benefit of the world and we're going to
make it be good not bad type thing and
you know if we can't make it be good
well then better not to exist so I think
that's a um uh that's kind of a a a
thing of that
um uh but it's it's an interesting
problem if you're trying to make a
company where you believe you in
informing the company want to make
something that is going to benefit the
world as well as benefit sort of the
narrow sort of commercial interest of uh
for example particular stockholders I
mean I know in my own sort of life and
times I've been interested in doing
things that I hope benefit the world and
you know that particular case because
because we have a simple private company
it's kind of just on me pretty much to
say I'm going to do these things which
benefit the world and I don't really
know for sure that they're going to
benefit the company I kind of think they
might but I don't know for sure you know
making wolf from Ala free to the world
for example it's not obvious that that
would be a benefit I don't know I it's
hard to tell you know it would be great
if people used wol malfa and then then
immediately started buying products from
us that's you know that pathway is is
not one that one can so convincingly
draw I when when um so you know that
decision to make wol from Alpa free to
the world or to make math world or to
make uh uh a lot of things I've done in
basic science and to make these things
free to the world it's like just give it
away um those are decisions which are
things that uh I hope and believe will
sort of benefit the world and I think
that's a a good thing to do um I can't
say whether those are things that um uh
you know it's a the if if we were a
company that had kind of public
shareholders for instance I'm sure we
would get many questions about well is
this really benefiting us the
shareholders um or is it just benefiting
the world which we shareholders don't
necessarily care about so I think that's
some uh you know it's a little bit of
background there perhaps
um uh anyway so
just a a story of of those things um I
could give you some other I'm not going
to give you the the um the the gossip
channel of um the story of open AI I
think um uh it's um it's one of these
things
where
where you
know
it's well let's let's let's just hope it
all has a happy ending um nightmare is
commenting I'm planning to write a
fantasy story about the antia device
cool sounds like a fun thing to do
um oh boy crab is asking about effective
altruism and I'm not sure I can
represent effective altruism terribly
well and it's a couple of Oxford based
philosophers who've been I
think primary pushers of it one of them
actually is also interested in in kind
of uh sort of theory of computation
meeting fundamental physics so uh I kind
of occasionally run across that person
in that context and I I had even made
the connection that he was also a big
effective altruism person you know I
think effectual altruism it kind of
sounds cool and it it um uh you know
it's kind of like I I suppose a rather
unfair summary would be you know lead
your life by making a bunch of money and
then giving it away to useful causes
type thing and don't feel bad might
making a bunch of money uh if you're
going to give it away away to uh uh to
good causes that's probably an unfair
sort of microcharacterization of of the
approach but you know at any given time
in history there are these approaches
that are kind of like you know they just
sound good and particularly they sound
good to the young it's kind of like well
like communism was one where in in
certainly in England I think in the US
as well in kind of the the let's say
1930s and so on 1920s maybe it's like
this sounds cool this is a good
theoretical idea
you know the fact that it well maybe
hasn't worked out so well so far in the
Soviet Union people didn't necessarily
know that and they were like well they
just didn't get the implementation right
it's still a good idea and I think that
there are these things that kind of seem
like seem like they're good ideas
because they seem kind of a modernizing
abstract abstracting kind of concept
another one that um I've run across from
time to time is this idea of holoc as a
way of organizing companies you know
companies tend to be organized
hierarchically there's a CEO and they
have people reporting to them and they
have people reporting to them and so on
you kind of draw a tree after to say in
a company like ours it's more of a graph
than a tree um and uh it's not as as
regimented as as as it might be uh I
think to its benefit but in any case one
of the sort of more extreme versions of
this is a so-called hocr where the
concept is there is no hierarchy the
companies run where a collection of of
intersecting Circles of people and you
know there are some companies that have
been tried to be run like this
s but by the way you know this is
typically the story of kind of history
and things that develop over a long
periods of time often the conventional
way of doing things by sort of a natural
selection process has ended up being
fairly sensible now the world changes so
sometimes these things that did make
sense in the past stop quite making
sense but usually kind of these radical
let's just do things very differently uh
things particularly when it comes to
sort of human and social organization
types of ideas they often don't end very
well and obviously effective altruism
well it's uh you know the the FDX story
was in supposedly very much a story of
uh kind of sort of following the
effective altruism path and I I know
some of the people who were involved in
that and I would say that there was a
you know I mean I would say a good faith
belief in sort of the value of effective
altruism and and and then it seems like
some of this the open AI story has come
from the effective altruism Direction um
and I don't know it's it's a perhaps the
way to say it is a lot of these things
they have a grain of interesting idea
but if you take them to too much of an
extreme they blow up in your face and
and perhaps that's what's happening here
and and of course the thing that can go
wrong then is you know yes there's but
there's still a grain of something
useful and then because one version of
it blew up in one's face and it's like
that's a bad idea let's get rid of that
that that thing Al together so I I don't
know how that will
land all right let's
see
uh this is a meta question can you talk
about the history of
podcasts um
gosh
uh can I
um you
know there sort of a thing enabled by
Audio on the internet um I think you
know blogs were an earlier thing web
logs as they were originally called that
was really the the the web log story was
I think in large part A I want to put
something up on the web how am I going
to do it oh I'm G to have to learn HTML
I'm G to have to get a server blah blah
blah and then they're started to be
these
platforms that uh basically let you sort
of edit things with an editor
and just say press the button and boom
it's a live web page social media things
like Facebook and so on Also Serve some
of that need and and earlier than that
Myspace and so on um the uh uh but you
know this was a this was a particular
form factor of delivering information
where it was kind of the idea was it was
a it was a writing based form and again
there were oh several companies which
have now long ago merged into things
that were merged into things and and
really for example WordPress um you know
became a thing that was sort of a second
generation of um uh kind of blogging
platform type type software but was kind
of like I want to put something out on
the web and um have it be uh have it be
easy to put out um and I don't think you
know in the early years when was that
gosh that must have
been
beginning of the 2000s right I think
that was later than the Myspace story
and um so so you know there's that and
then there's kind of the audio version
of that of podcasts and that required
kind of Internet audio to work well and
and uh uh and then of course live
streaming required kind of well internet
video to work well to tell you a little
bit of a story about that back well
actually funny it's It's a small world
you know back I first met like Sam
ultman and actually EMT Shear uh who was
briefly CEO of open AI might even be
still today I'm not sure um I met them
both because they were part of the first
cohort of why combinator uh
entrepreneurs white combinator was this
operation started by Paul Graham who I'd
known previously it was originally down
in Boston and it was kind of like hey
college kids uh come to Boston for the
summer and start companies and uh among
the companies that were started in that
first group were Reddit and um uh well
let's see what were there a bunch of
them um and and there was was kind of
anyway so there was a
um uh why am I bringing this up oh yes
I'm bringing this up because there were
these two guys EMT Shar and Justin K who
had a company called Kiko which was a
web calendar company which I have to say
uh well one of my kids who happened who
was quite young at the time who happened
to be exposed to all this stuff said
that's the one to invest in you should
invest in that one which I almost did
but some people at my company who were
like well we know about calendar systems
we use them all the time were not
impressed by the distance that this one
had got but in any case that was uh
those two worked on that eventually they
sold that company on eBay for like
$50,000 or something then they started
another company called twitch and um
actually in between those two they
started a company called justin.tv which
was a kind of a reality TV show of
Justin can's life as seen by a a camera
attached to a kind of a hat that he was
wearing um and that was sort of an a a a
gimmick type thing that must have been
what was that that must
been 2007 maybe on that order 2006
perhaps um
and uh so that was kind of a gimmick
that started sort of a live streaming of
your life type thing idea subsequently
that turned into twitch which then
started what initially seemed like the
absolutely bizar idea of live streaming
things like uh uh people playing video
games and also live streaming now things
like this live stream um but uh uh you
know as a sort of footnote to history
one of the places where Justin .tv was
used was in the launch of wol malfa in
May 2009 uh we were sort of setting up
this whole launch we had no idea how
many people were going to access wolf
malfa on day one and we knew we had
servers that would deal with a certain
volume of traffic we had no idea whether
that volume of traffic was correct and
we had no idea whether the whole thing
would just sort of fall over and and die
based on the amount of traffic we had so
we thought let's at least make it
interesting for the world to see this
process happen let's live stream the
launch of or malfa so we uh we built
this actually that caused us to build
this kind of nice mission control like
uh place with very nice displays showing
kind of traffic volumes and so on we
still use many of those displays today
they were they were kind of conveniently
built in their nice and ergonomic and so
on but they were originally built for
sort of the made for TV version of the
launch of or malfa which we streamed on
Justin.tv and I'm sure you you can still
find that live stream it was uh um for a
while it seemed like it was going to be
the world's most boring piece of
Television because all that was going to
happen was at some moment you know we
were going to press a button and thing
was going to be live but actually of
course things went wrong the most
spectacular of which was that this was
the actual sort of data center we were
using was in in Illinois and that day
that afternoon that early evening there
was a tornado that was approaching our
location and uh right at the time it was
expected to arrive right at the time we
had sort of advertised the launch and
actually the tornado went a different
way so that became a non a non problem
but it was for a while it looked like a
a a quite dramatic problem but uh anyway
that that's um that was sort of piece of
the early history of um
uh of uh of live streaming and so on all
right we should probably WP up uh for
now here and next time I'll be back in
my natural habitat and um uh um look
forward to talking about some of the
things people have asked about here
today and more things in the future so
thanks very much and uh bye for
now